c'est toujours un grand moment de sport
voilà plus qu'une heure avant le top
départ
ultime échauffement dernier briefing
moment de concentration pour les 2600
trailer présent à l'île de loisirs de 50
ans en Yvelines il s'apprête à s'élancer
pour le 80 km de l’écotrail
mais ça va être super magnifique on va
partir trop vite
pour pouvoir accélérer sur la faille
garder du jus quoi alors que la pluie
était annoncée ce samedi 18 mars le
soleil finalement rendez-vous de la
matinée une 16e édition qui s'annonce
sous de bons auspices on a plus le choix
là on a tout le monde est dans les
starting là ça fait une semaine que
toute l'équipe d'orgas et à fond moi ça
fait même des mois et des mois et là on
est on est prêt on attend juste que le
départ soit donné avec les coureurs
puissent s'amuser créé en 2008 l'écho
trails Paris promu une pratique de la
course à pied correspondable au menu 5
traits les deux marches nordiques de
quoi satisfaire tous les profils
fidéliser les habitués à tirer de
nouveaux venus
en de 45 45 km parce qu'en fait c'est
une course éco-responsable au 80% on se
déroule dans les milieux urbain et que
je partage avec mes amis on habite à
côté donc ça passe devant la maison
sympa on connaît on connaît les bois par
coeur c'est la maison c'est notre jardin
moi j'aime bien remonter à Paris chaque
printemps ici il y a tous mes potes sur
Paris alors c'est vrai que c'est rare de
revenir des Alpes pour les cotterelles
mais bon c'est ça change ça change de
terrain c'est sympa très excité à l'idée
de d'arriver à la Tour Eiffel et de et
de profiter de de ce magnifique paysage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à 11h30 le départ du 80 km est donné les
coureurs vont tenter de rejoindre le
premier étage de la Tour Eiffel
le tour de l'île de loisirs pour aller
rejoindre derrière but que la forêt
domaniale de Meudon à Chaville le
domaine de Saint-Cloud et puis après
tout droit jusqu'à la tour Eiffel et
puis les 137 dernières marches pour
franchir la ligne d'arrivée après
seulement 5h42 minutes et 40 secondes
Yohann stock ça juge la 16e édition de
l'écoterelle Paris chez les hommes Katie
Scheide s'impose du côté des femmes en 6
heures 23 minutes les couterraines paris
2023 réunis près de 13000 participants
sur l'ensemble des courses proposées le
rendez-vous est pris pour l'année
prochaine